well this week 71 Labour MPs put their
names to a letter calling for a second
referendum or a people's fate and
yesterday Labour's Shadow brexit
secretary appeared to take the party one
step closer to backing one but there is
frustration among someone the Labour
benches the party's leadership isn't
quite there yet well joining us now is a
David Lammy and thank you very much for
being with us on the program today
now you're perhaps one of the most vocal
supporters of a second referendum I just
want to put directly to you some of what
people were telling me in Whitstable and
I can just pull a quote up and just so
we can know exactly what we're talking
about this is from a young man called
Jack Ryan a fisherman he said I voted
already and if they take it back to
another vote because they haven't got
the answer they wanted then what's the
point in his even voting I think that is
a sentiment that comes back again and
again what's the point in me voting if
it's just gonna be ignored
I understand that I was in Peterborough
a few weeks ago and people were saying
similar things they're really frustrated
with Westminster and politicians for not
coming up with a solution but the point
is this we either leave with No Deal and
that is a very painful brexit which it
looks to me like parliament has ruled
out all we leave with a deal that is
hatched by parliamentarians which is
probably a pointless brexit and Norway
plus is that pointless brexit because
frankly we'll be leaving we still have
free movement we'd still be paying you a
lot of money and for all of those
reasons it seems to me that the deal
that emerges that parliamentarians can
get around needs to have the informed
consent of the British population
because many people a leavers and
remainders will feel that they didn't
vote for it you see that's the thing
informed consent because I think a lot
of people would think actually they were
well informed the first time around and
actually it's quite patronizing friend
peeks to say that they didn't really
know what they were voting well let's be
honest a lot of water has passed under
the bridge to resume lost by two hundred
and thirty-odd votes we are now in a
mess it's a constitutional crisis it's
not clear that
is a majority for any deal in fact so
what we can't do is crash out which is
painful I hope a deal emerges and it's a
soft brexit but it does seem to me that
there is a risk that we upset both
leavers and remain errs if basically
Westminster hatches the deal and signs
and delivers it and many people think I
didn't actually vote for this so that
reason that you've got to have a final
say the British people has to RIT has
got to resolve this and I've said this
before Sophie you cannot argue that you
undermined democracy with more democracy
it's just not the way that some great
nations like ours establish themselves
but some people would feel that it is -
my own democracy that it's their voices
being ignored are you not worried about
some of the consequences for the country
if we have to go through another
referendum before when the first one was
sowed devices look we've seen the
division in the country we see it
outside Westminster with the way that
some members of the public often on the
hard right are behaving towards
parliamentarians we see it in families
that are divided across this country yes
of course we have to bring this to an
end but it seems to me that the way to
bring it to an end is to present the
British people no longer with this leave
and we don't understand what the terms
of leaving are this time we understand
exactly what the terms of leaving are
when we get that deal the Parliament can
sign off or indeed we can remain within
the European Union which is the option I
prefer let's be clear on that because
we've looked into the abyss and decided
sorry not for us okay and you said and a
little bit earlier in the interview and
that you hope a deal is done does that
mean that there is a brexit deal that
you could vote for well certainly I
would prefer a soft brexit somewhere
like Norway to Tereza males watch deal
that got us nowhere and they might
reject it was on the table
it's the terms under which it was put I
am very clear and I'm writing in the
observer today that I could only vote
for it on the basis that there was a
final say referendum because if you're
someone let's say in a Labour heartland
constituency you thought you were
getting an end to free movement and
politicians have taken that off the
table you thought you weren't gonna be
paying into the money into the EU and
politicians are now saying we are gonna
still be paying money into the EU and
and worse you're now subject to all the
rules of the European Union without a
say then my god surely we've got to ask
the British people if they're up for
that that's only fair
so of course economically it would be
less damaging but my view is look let's
stay in the European Union and actually
have an influence on free movement
actually have an influence on the rules
and actually have an influence on
bureaucracy red tape and monies that's
my view let's see what the British
people think and how would you describe
Labor's current position on brexit well
look I think we've got an open goal here
and I'd like the Labour Party to go
through the door and score the goal and
the only way of doing that it seems to
me is to get us into a place where we
are preparing for that final say
referendum that has to take place he's
hitting the crossbar well he's moving
the goalposts and I I've been very clear
on that you know we we now have seen
that the deal has not gone through that
a vote of confidence has not been
successful as people like me predicted
back in September last year it seems to
me there's no point continuing with
votes of no confidence you know throwing
darts but actually is missing a board
elections going to happen I think an
election is extremely unlikely because
members of the DUP are not going to put
Jeremy Corbyn who has been a long term
friend of shim fain into number 10 let's
be clear and even
Dominic grieve and a Subaru are not
saying that they are going to vote no
confidence in a Conservative government
which they prefer to Jeremy Corbyn so I
don't see any prospects of a general
election no we've what we've got to do
is get around what the alternative deal
is but be clear that we should set in
place the timetable now to get that
second referendum that's a final say
referendum and let's be clear on this
the only way we're now going to get a
brexit is if the labour party whips for
it so the question is is the Labour
Party going to whip for Teresa Mays
brexit or is the Labour Party going to
get clear on the options for the British
people the best options of the British
people and my view the best options for
the British people is now to remain
within the european union jeremy
corbyn's always talked about the
importance of party democracy about
listening to the party members the
conference motion were saying that they
want to push for a general election if
you can't get that then a second
referendum is her on the table now as
you've said a general election seems
unlikely you've had the confidence
version vote and lost so why do you
think it is that the party isn't
explicitly backing a second referendum
and do you think Jeremy Corbyn is going
back on some of those very strong words
he's used in the past about the
importance of listening to membership
well I think kirsten was very clear
yesterday the moment has arrived the
moment has arrived for clarity and for
leadership and for those of us that have
campaigned for a final say people's vote
we are absolutely clear that requires
the labour party to whip for not done it
well look I think the jeremy corbyn's
i think that jeremy has been hedging I
recognised that he has had a national
leadership role and if we went back two
and a half years is absolutely clear
that the Labour Party like the
Conservative Party was split on this
issue but as we have travelled two and a
half years as we see the mess that
Theresa May is created as we see the red
lines that she has
in place opinions have changed across
the country and they've absolutely
changed across the Labor Party and the
labor movement and now is the time for
leadership and let me say this Sophie
there are a small group in our party who
are so frustrated who have so much
grievance the fear is that they're going
to go off and form another party I
personally reject that but the danger is
just like 1983 a new party built around
basically a relationship with Europe
keeps the Labour Party out of power for
a generation how many I don't want to
see that I have no idea that you would
have heard a speculation like me and one
sees colleagues behaving in certain ways
please let us unite the Labour Party now
unite the Labour Party around the idea
and the concept that ultimately whatever
now happens it's clear that the British
people need a final say on the deal
that's going to be hashed in the
corridors of Westminster in the coming
weeks okay well let's put some of that
later to a member of the shadow cabinet
David Lammy thank you very much